and I'm going to start talking while you
take your seats so that we don't get too
far behind
let me introduce myself my name is
Madeline's Ellen and I am currently
acting director of the Weatherhead East
Asian Institute the mission of the
weather head east asian institute since
its founding in 1949 has been directed
both inward at training new generations
of experts in the humanities Social
Sciences and the professions at Columbia
but also outward to enhance
understanding of East Asia in the wider
community including the global community
and also working with teachers and
others around the country and trying to
make a better understanding of East Asia
possible undergraduate education and the
creation of overseas opportunities for
undergraduates to deepen their regional
knowledge and language skills to
participate in internships and to engage
in individual research have been an
increasingly important part of that
mission and in recent years this has led
us to work with many of our colleagues
who are actually here in the audience
and and some of our colleagues who are
not here across the university as
columbia established its global centers
whose directors we are very excited to
say are here today we've also been
working with our fellow regional
institutes with cgt and I CLS to create
the interact teaching collaborative
whose postdoctoral fellows also bring a
very important new global perspective to
undergraduate teaching on campus and
this summer we did something new I would
really say it's a kind of adventure in
globalizing undergraduate education in
the form of the global scholars programs
summer workshop that these young people
participated in I have to say a few
things as background and then I'm going
to make some thank yous and I'm going to
turn the the the program over to them
but I think it's important to note that
but as president Bolger said the
International is not a new thing I
Columbia scholars especially those of us
who work on parts of the world other
than the United States have been
incorporating a kind of globality in
their work for a very long time and you
see a lot of that coming out in the
kinds of things that our students are
talking about when they go out into the
world and look for projects so we've
taken methods developed for the study of
one place and applied them to another
place we apply comparative frameworks to
multiple sites we read place a through
the eyes of place B we look for things
that are unique to help us better
understand those aspects of the human
experience that we share and we are
going to keep doing these things no
matter what happens with the internet
and everything else because these are
the very foundation of what education is
about we also continue to believe in the
importance of sending students abroad to
deepen their language skills to develop
specialized regional knowledge and so on
but if this is the this is the only
thing that we do we will undoubtedly
continue to be the leaders amongst the
leaders in International Studies that we
have been for some time but we're not
really going to be globalizing education
for this we've come to conclude we need
to develop new ways to enable students
to have the opportunity to engage with
the world in diverse settings and we've
seen some of that already in the in the
wonderful presentations of the Paris
program and last summer the WEA I
undertook a pilot program the details of
what you're going to hear in a moment in
which faculty members grubbin young and
Robbie Barnett took eleven students not
all of them are up here on the podium to
spend six intensive weeks studying
issues of environment and in issues of
poverty
in urban settings and very important
urban settings of Beijing Shanghai and
Mumbai as an academic program the
workshop provided these students with a
highly sophisticated multi-site social
science field research experience which
i hope you'll hear about but what really
excited me as a teacher was the
opportunities that this combination of
rigorous research in two different parts
of the world provided these students
with an opportunity to engage and i
think the word engage is really
important here to engage in a different
kind of learning one that's really based
on encounter with the varied actors who
both experience and attempt to influence
the conditions of life on the ground in
multiple global settings one could say
that the everyday of the people that our
students encountered in China and in
India in one sense challenged them to
bring specificity to a lot of the
generalizations and theories that we're
so good at teaching them but also
provided a very vivid experience of the
impact that different backgrounds
different cultures different education
different life experiences different
institutional interests have on our
interpretive positions because they were
meeting people with all those different
things the fact that this was a group
experience I think was extremely
important to us providing a unified
focus but also giving them an
opportunity to constantly engage in
feedback and critique amongst themselves
and equally important I think was the
requirement that they come back to
campus and participate in a specially
created seminar in which they are now in
a sense unpacking the lessons that they
learned in applying them to analytically
very rigorous writing projects this was
a a process of very
eep immersion but like any real-world
encounter it couldn't be scripted and my
impression from reading the wonderful
evaluations that we received already
from students and from from their
professors is that this was really also
an opportunity to hone resilience to
hone techniques of collaborative work to
hone your skills and written and oral
presentations and these are all things
that people are going to take with them
when they go out into the larger world
and when most of them don't become
professors and scholars now most people
don't realize how many people it takes
to put something like this together and
I want to start by thanking for
president Bollinger for his financial
support for the GSP program and also for
his vision and encouragement of our
efforts and and we're really especially
excited that he's come to spend this
evening with us I also want to thank our
global center partners in this endeavor
dr. ken Pruitt the former VP of the gold
global centers dr. South juan mari
current vp and during the time this was
going on acting director of the global
center east asia dr. Naropa bajpai
director of the global center mumbai
they and their staff on the ground were
amazing and you really need the global
centers to be able to do something like
this and I think that that it really
taught us that the global centers are
going to be a major force in how we
reconfigure global education on campus I
also want to thank Michael Piven jur
Dean of undergraduate global programs
and associate dean they drew they shared
with us extensive experience and
expertise and how you carry out an
overseas program they help keep us
focused because like we're just excited
you know and and and they helped us keep
our students safe which
is really important under sometimes very
challenging circumstances in the field
and we're also grateful that they're
continuing to work with us as we
evaluate lessons learned in devise ways
to make next year's program as
successful as possible i also want to
thank faculty of the south asian
institute especially on a row and geeta
mehta who worked with our students who
helped us develop our syllabi the dean's
office is at Columbia College it sees
that GS at Barnard were amazingly
supportive and gave us very interesting
and important critical feedback and I
want to thank hazel Mae for helping us
Shepherd the syllabi through the COI and
the IRB process I our IRB is you most of
you don't know what that's all about and
I also want to extend my personal thanks
to the extraordinary staff at the WEA I
who are amongst the best people I've
worked with in an institution for
overseeing the execution of this project
at every every stage in every mind you
detail I want to thank Provost John
cotesworth who sends his regards to us
even though he couldn't be here and
executive vice president for the Arts
and Sciences Nick Dirk's who you're
going to hear from in a minute and I
also want to take a moment to thank our
donor alweather head and his wife Celia
al is no longer with us but we never
could have done all these things without
the support that they gave us and so for
those of you who find the presentations
you're about to hear interesting
exciting I want to say that we're happy
to tell you that we're planning to do it
again this coming summer we expect to
undertake this the summer in
collaboration with the Institute for
Latin American Studies and the Santiago
global Center one of our newest global
centers but but they're right there with
us and we look forward to your continued
support
to the participation of a new cohort of
amazing Columbia and Barnard students
who are going to go overseas now I want
to turn the the mic over to is Robbie up
here with you guys I can't oh there you
are to a 22 Robert Barnett and who is a
I guess I would define you as a
contemporary cultural historian that's
what I've decided you are but is also
the head of our modern Tibetan Studies
program so you can see how how far and
wide we wander in our in our
explorations of the globe and you will
leave thank you very much well our
project our course is really a joint
collective effort and our scholars our
young students are going to present the
program to you themselves and to present
their experiences of that program I'm
going to mention just a couple of the
design principles that were used in
putting it together it had two parts as
you know one in China that was developed
by Professor Corbin young a very eminent
sociologist and it focused on
environmental issues in urban China and
particularly the role of environmental
ngos the India part of the program which
I developed together with Jake Astoria
South Asian 'used PhD who's here and
support from faculty a new row a gita
meter Denise Burnett and also from my
Institute the weather had Michael
Pittenger and outstanding support from
new open box pie in bone Mumbai and his
team our program was a little different
it focused on a different topic the
topic of poverty and slum rehabilitation
issues in Bombay it it focused on the
range of social actors involved in that
but it reflected the nature of Indian
society the open culture of discourse
that is so welcoming
to visitors there it also had
intellectual principles one was one
really came from Michael pittenger which
is to offer all the things that a
classroom can't offer within a framework
of rigorous intellectual inquiry it
focused as you heard on the principle of
direct encounter with the social actors
involved in dealing with these issues
primarily through through lectures and
meetings with local experts and local
players it was a program which
encouraged students to acquire method
and methodology as much as or more than
to acquire knowledge we emphasized
practice and practice based approaches
and we emphasized a range of
perspectives from the people we met and
therefore we included local students as
a fundamental core part of our program
and finally we we problematize some
issues for the students we problematized
the notion of the single or dominant
theory we invited them to try different
explanatory models for their findings we
problematize the notion of the expert we
rejected the idea of the parachuted the
fireman that can come in and find a
solution for someone else's problem and
we looked more at processes of trying to
understand rather than to find and and
finally we even tried to question the
notion of comparison itself and the
assumptions that sometimes go with that
and to encourage the idea of thinking in
terms of specific context in which we
find situations our students now are
going to talk to you about their
experiences of the program they've
divided themselves into three groups the
first group of four are going to reflect
on the features of the program as an
educational model how did that work for
them the second group of three are going
to give a sense of the actual encounters
they had in China
India and the third group are going to
talk about the research questions that
came out of this work to give you a
sense an impression of some of those so
I had you over now to our first group is
Julie brother might grab that microphone
hello everyone my name is Stephanie Jang
and as Professor Barnett mentioned I
will begin our discussion about the
global scholar program Asia's
educational model I'll never forget the
first NGO we met with in India after
their presentation we SAT around the
conference table in an over
air-conditioned meeting room at the
mumbai global center eating the still
curious foods from the Tiffin's perched
upon our labs as the room began to buzz
with small talk professor Barnett who
was sitting to my left sidle towards me
on his rolling chair and asked me in a
very serious whisper what did you think
about that who do you think their
enemies are luckily luckily I was able
to resist my initial urge which was also
to laugh and I tried to consider the
question as seriously as I could I found
myself completely unable to respond I
was stunned by the immediate question
who do you think their enemies are and
further puzzled by a larger
unfamiliarity with the situation at hand
why did this professor seem to care
about my opinion as undergrads we spend
a lot of time riddled by academic and
security in freshman and sophomore years
the core provides small classroom
interactions with professors who come to
intimately know their students early
college goals academic or otherwise
after that a lot of us are left is fish
out of water we either figure out how to
construct our own academic networks from
the ground up or we don't the group
nature of this project can find combined
pardon me with an emphasis on
learning over having learned meant that
we had to navigate Andrey navigate the
events of our field experiences together
sharing earnest and engaging
conversations like that first unexpected
one with Professor Barnett intern
communicating openly over the course of
our research reinforced an academic
network based on intellectual honesty
curiosity and care something I
considered an all but lost cause since
freshmen and sophomore years certainly
this isn't the only way students can
build meaningful academic relationships
but for me this collective research
experience provided the necessary
backdrop to forge those important
intellectual bonds in trying to distill
the advantages and disadvantages of the
global Scholar Program Asia's
educational model or methodology we
realized that we were all drawn to
different facets of the program
structure or conversely we're drawn to
the same facets for very different
reasons now a few of my peers will
discuss their own personal experiences
with the course
hello my name is Connie Chang so three
years ago during my freshman year I took
a course across the street on lifeguard
swimming at the very beginning of that
semester I remember having to take a
practice test in fact I remember this
incident quite well because frankly I
thought I was going to drown carrying a
10-pound weight from one end of the pole
to the other I'm pleased to say that the
global scholars program this summer did
not include a life or death situation
but I like to think of this experience
as being as similar to being turned into
a watery abyss not yet able to swim but
surrounded by the safety of a net we
were all tossed into these very
different cultures and by cultures I
don't mean just the Chinese versus
Indian versus American I have in mind a
smaller scale and many times
unpredictable cultures like when
haggling for leather sandals and claw
becausewe are discussing the
implications of Beijing cab drivers
taste in music yes through this program
i received the chance to see firsthand
very things to encounter in our
education here issues and conditions
that at the very most we learn about
through a narrative of another this time
we had access to the general little
things things that may seem
insignificant when you read our heal
them that is until you find yourself in
that situation and it begins to unveil a
very different story because he just so
happened to be there at that specific
location and point in time when we were
brought up to the village of wagon each
awadi an architect shared with us this
water system proposal involving the
application of some species of seaweed
into brown water hindsight makes me
wonder whether i would have readily
absorbed idea hadn't said glanced across
it in a published book of humanitarian
design projects but i was worried that
day because after experiencing the half
hour walk up the hill and seeing the
children watch us with curiosity the
woman holding babies one question begs
to be asked would it really work
I found their program structured laxity
structured and that it was in essence
and academic program of a pre-planned
list of groups and individuals to me but
lacks in that we were not balancer
research bias encouraged us to be more
attuned to our surroundings and to
develop our own viewpoints we saw
different perspectives on rather simple
topics like skywalks you DRI just one of
the few organizations we met criticize
them for elevating people into midair
just to make driving more comfortable
you'd pranaam one of the HR students we
worked with lies on them regularly to
void the Mumbai traffic below structure
laxity is merely one feature of the
globe or scholar poem I appreciated for
encouraged me to seek a balance between
a critical mind and an open mind my name
is Mike door instead and before I came
to Columbia I lived a very pragmatic
life I worked as a retail sales manager
for a growing company in New Jersey
where my professional metrics were
solely based on factors of profitability
needless to say experiences a sales
manager in this sort of environment has
brought me to always see the bottom line
in business and the company of Human
Rights sustainability Urban Studies and
architecture students my point of view
certainly fell into the minority meeting
with NGOs and social enterprises
alongside these ten other students
allowed each of our diverse outlooks to
stand out as distinct and independent
voices in every meeting a salient
example of this came out came out of our
meeting with water wallow a social
enterprise that promotes the supply that
promotes the supply of clean water and
Mumbai's most infamous slum darabi water
wallah operates as both an NGO and as a
private enterprise with a retail
location within the slum the retail into
their business does not offer does not
differ greatly from contemporary retail
methodologies in the u.s. insofar as the
primary purpose of the sales person is
to educate the
customer and make a sale based on fresh
information in this case on the benefits
of clean and reliable water supplies we
visited their store and I was amazed to
see that none of their water purifiers
were in use so the customers could not
see the demonstrated benefit of this
important technology immediately my
inner sales manager joined the
conversation and I began to ask Jennifer
the chief development officer of water
wala about the hard sales figures
including costs pricing lines of credit
from manufacturers and most importantly
why water while it chose to choose chose
to that shows the specific line of
products that they did I was shocked to
learn that the private enterprise was
hemorrhaging cash due to minut margins
poor sales performance and remarkably
high overhead to costs we were told
before entering the slum that water
while is located on what would be der
avie's Fifth Avenue the haphazard
cobbled roadway there was no wider than
20 feet at any point was lined with
structures in various states of decay
none of which were taller than two or
three stories under the shade of these
structures I saw that everyone
everywhere seemed to be swatting flies
away from their wares and pre cooked
fried food directly behind a fruit stand
across the street from Walla Walla there
was a huge mound of mixed trash forcing
the fruit vendor to fight ever more
vigorously against the advances of an
excited swarm of flies at this point I
stopped focusing my inner sales manager
on jennifer and i started listening to
what my peers had to say i quickly
realized that while i was grilling
jennifer on the company's lack of
profitability after a year in business
my peers were stuck on a completely
different aspect of the organization
stephanie and cecilia were having their
own intense interview with saeed
regarding water wallahs methodology of
community outreach at first thought I
cast out this point of view as
ill-informed due to the low likelihood
of water Wallace sustained financial
future but it soon occurred to me that I
was missing a very large piece of the
water while a puzzle this was a firm
that was trying to sustain itself while
servicing a community in dire need of
help and there was no one else hitting
the pavement with half the passion or
commitment as the water wallet team they
were promulgating a future filled with
filled with clean water for every
household in Mumbai's slums the
convergence of differing intellectual
curiosity and the global Scholars
Program gave me and I believe that the
ten other students that are sitting here
with me today the opportunity to engage
with otherwise foreign academic
ideologies the experience of water while
it gave me the chance to be more than
just the bottom line it allowed me to
see things from the viewpoint of my
peers and as much I had the opportunity
to engage with these important problems
in ways that I could have overlooked
otherwise meetings meetings like this
helped me see the innate benefit of
academic and intellectual diversity
within a group and I could have not
could not have wished for more valuable
out come out of this program thank you
I'm grace Vickers um and it's been
incredibly important to me as an
undergraduate as I plan my academic and
professional futures to have had this
experience of deeply thinking about what
it means to engage in research my two
years at Columbia have on the one hand
greatly expanded the opportunities that
I now know are possible but on the other
hand has often left me completely lost
as to how to take advantage of those
opportunities wanting to attend graduate
school in the future I know that at that
time I will also be asked to design and
implement my own research proposals and
carry them out and now that I've taken
the time as an undergraduate to not only
acquire the practical skills that I'll
need but an understanding of the methods
and activity of research itself I feel
confident and prepared for my academic
future beyond my undergraduate education
that GSP has no formal research
experience prerequisite helped to make
this experience possible that no one in
our group came into the program
thoroughly set and his or her ways but
instead open to learning about and
exploring new ideas and methods of
research created the intellectual space
necessary in which to reflect on those
methods and their consequences for
example in India we met with several
different groups active in slum
redevelopment and as was made clear in
our readings and through our visits with
them people have been studying
Indian sums for decades both from within
and outside the city of Mumbai and India
before the program I was confused as to
what I would be able to contribute to
this conversation and I was concerned
that my presence as a researcher was
illegitimate though I still struggle
with these concerns our visits to two of
the best-known groups working in slums
pukar and spark have helped me begin to
see ways of overcoming that these
organizations are able to collect the
data and produce the results that they
do because they've developed ties with
the communities in which they work that
their relationship to the people in
spaces they study is less defined as the
difference between insider and outsider
as much as it is the difference between
taking from and giving back to
communities as members of the educated
elite the leaders of oaths park and
pukar are in many ways outsiders
themselves but by providing avenues in
which to empower community members to be
the ones engaging in research
specifically through the youth research
fellowship program epic are the
organizations have found other means of
legitimizing their work it's a dynamic
that I don't think I would have begun I
would have begun understanding had I
simply been reading about it and keeping
it in mind will certainly make the
future research that I undertake
especially the semester far more
productive as our individual stores have
highlighted certain components of the
program's design whether the clothes
academic relationships it fosters its
structured laxity the convergence of
academic disciplines and perspectives
that it allows or the opportunity to
engage with different research
methodologies has shaped our personal
and collective experiences as both
students and researchers thank you very
much
hello my name is Pablo Mota I'm an
international student from Mexico at the
school of general studies and majoring
in urban studies this is my senior year
so pretty exciting just one more to go
my group this is josh and certainly
would like to talk about our encounters
during our program who we met the
contents of these encounters and some
examples of them i will try to briefly
introduce you to these questions and
answers and to continue giving you an
idea of what we what we went through
through the six weeks that the program
took we met with lots of people actually
more than 130 members of ngos local and
national governments professors students
of universities filmmakers reporters
professionals and a lot of people that
were were part of the civil society most
of these people our active citizens
interested in the main problems and
challenges their countries regions
regions and cities face today they are
analyzing and observing ingrained and
the brood rooted problems that affect
children in migrants workers women
disadvantaged communities the poor and
the dispossessed in these encounters
three major things stand out the first
one is that we want to learn about the
major organization and environmental
challenges that there are in Beijing
Shanghai and Mumbai but during the
program as we were paired with students
from major local academic institutions
they also wanted to learn from us at all
times there was a continuous exchange of
ideas experiences and ways of thinking
that included not only China India and
the US but also experiences from all
over the world that both cohorts of
students brought with them the second
one is that we experience firsthand and
from primary sources the economic
political and social systems in both
countries their pros and the cons we met
and learned from the very actors who are
trying to change those cons
mainly NGOs and grassroots organizations
in our meetings we sat down with key
people making change happen
notwithstanding the many adversities
they faced the third one and no less
important point relates to what
President Bulger just said minutes ago
in this trip we discovered what we don't
know which is a lot by the way in
Colombia to let me explain in Colombia
tradition we were we were given a big
bunch of pre-departure ratings and we
were required to continue reading
endless articles along the trip no
matter how busy the agendas of each
shape of each they were in spite of
these insightful readings under a deep
content as we met people and sat down
with more actors an immense number of
additional questions emerged so to be
honest at the end of our research we
came back with more questions and
answers but I think that is exactly what
this type of programs are aiming at to
scratch at the surface of some of the
main issues of society to spark our
interest beyond their graduates interest
and make us dig deeper on them as we
research during our time at Columbia
that is already happening as we're some
of those are trying to write our thesis
for the senior earlier and the capstone
seminar is also trying to aim at that so
so that's basically what what we went
through I know I try to adjust to go
over the academic part of it thank
hi there um I want to talk a little bit
about the influence that being with the
academics that we were with had on us
and also about the the people that they
brought to us so they overall I would
view it as something that sort of
created Road markers and refocused us
and reshaped our views at different
points throughout it was very easy to
take the views of the different experts
in each field that we met with at face
value and you know from from the moment
we were accepted to the program
professor Barnett set up meetings for us
with professors here at Columbia who
were able to sort of give us ideas about
things to look out for and also about
pitfalls to be aware of and while they
did create some biases that we also
needed to you know check ourselves on
they gave us a sort of springboard that
allowed us to get deeper into these
issues than we ever could have without
people who had been studying these
fields for a very long time could have
given us and so one of the other things
that academics brought to us is showing
us what academic conflict means and what
uncertainty means and just how certain
even some of the experts are we learned
about the importance of different
perspectives and we learned what it
meant to navigate these different
perspectives the way we were thinking
about it is you know we didn't
necessarily hesitate to ask the hard
questions but we nonetheless got harder
and more difficult answers so
on one instance we visited an
institution called the Tata Institute of
Social Sciences for a talk on religion
and caste based social exclusion in
India and we got to witness firsthand
how people who we assumed were the
experts on caste based exclusion in
India be sort of go head-to-head with
RTA on the program and we witnessed an
extremely heated debate between a number
of people sort of supervising the
program with us and it at least for me
at that point made a lot of things come
crumbling down because we had known that
we needed to question people but the
academics were some of the people we
took most seriously and really believe
that you know these people were able to
chart some paths for us that made it a
little easier and then things came
crumbling down once again but I think
everywhere we went between professor
Barnett and professor yang access was
created between their personal
connections and connections through the
global center that they cultivated that
helped us have meetings with different
people whether that was assembling a
panel of experts in Beijing for us or
bringing in a movie director who could
talk to us about issues he sees in the
Indian city and the important thing was
that they brought us to their own
research and there was a period where I
was upset that the research workshop
didn't involve a research workshop for
three hours a day but in the sense of a
serie a class that was teaching me how
to research but what I quickly learned
was that the research workshop was being
in the room with people who do research
for a living and very well and
having them take our work seriously and
lead us down a path of doing serious
research with them thank you hi my name
is Cecilia i'm also an urban studies
senior this is a very exciting trip and
as some other students mentioned we were
lucky enough to get to study with a
group of chinese students and indian
students in their respective countries
and I think we enjoyed getting to know
these students on a personal level you
know getting dragged home to their
houses and going out to karaoke but I
think also importantly what we were able
to learn about their academic and
community and political engagement was
on a research level very as valuable as
some of our more formally arranged
research interviews or meetings so I
think what a lot of us were able to
observe through our interactions with
our peers is a really big difference
between how say Chinese students and
Indian students interacted with us and
interacted with our subject matter in in
the classroom or when we'd have
discussions about what we were doing
that day or at our field sites and we
saw some Indian students really really
engaging and fighting the political
narrative and trying to create these
changes in their communities while we
have a much harder time coaxing
conversations out of our Chinese
counterparts and there was a lot more
hesitancy and reticence on their part to
talk about a lot of things and I think
kind of our time with these students
brought up a lot of really important
questions like how the political
infrastructure of a country really
affects the extent to which you can
engage with people with your research
subjects if that's what you want to call
them but also just to your width and
also how political and cultural norm
kind of influencing the extent to which
an academic dialogue you have is viable
or even what information you consider
viable or data or research so by the end
of the trip we had eaten a lot of
strange and spicy food and explored some
parts of of Beijing and Shanghai that I
don't think we would have on our own but
more importantly I think interacting
with these students really helped us
question our own academic approaches and
our American academic approach or
whatever country we were from and there
was a lot of kind of like Pablo said a
lot of questions that we came away with
and I think we also came a lot away with
a lot of questions we didn't ask and
this is an exciting thing for all of us
yeah hi my name is a mark choy and I'm a
junior at Columbia College majoring in
economics and philosophy at this time
we'd like to talk about some of the
research findings during our time in
India and China one of the most
important factors note is that most of
Education was based on direct experience
assume my other fellow global scholars
have mentioned we're able to learn
deeply about globalization and
urbanization in India and China sorry
you couldn't hear from first hand
exposure to the issues at hand for
example we had ample opportunity to
visit the legal dwellings of migrant
populations in both countries and this
is an incredibly real testament to the
injustice and inequalities of rapid
urbanization in China not only that we
read about the issues of air pollution
in Beijing we've got to experience it
ourselves through the days of incredible
smog where it would be impossible to see
past just a few hundred feet
and on the lack of the most basic public
services and infrastructure in India we
were able to experience this firsthand
as well we visited and met the residents
of dt Ravi slums we felt the bumps and
bruises of the private roads and we even
got to experience poor conditions of
sanitation and the public water supply
because alternative students standing
here today were ill in bed for at least
a portion of our trip we all fought case
of a fever and stomach viruses and
actually one person only one person
didn't get bill and that's our Superman
Pablo right here and so whether we were
all incredibly ill or walking through to
Mumbai slums or even walking through
slumps while we were ill first an
exposure and analysis is certainly what
working in the field is all about
theoretical models data and proposed
solutions based on our readings merely
served as a complementary source and
with our own eyes we were able to
confirm whether data and our readings
was accurate and if and also if the
solutions to the issues of environment
and globalisation proposed by authors
was actually feasible of course this
doesn't necessarily mean we are
currently capable of providing effective
solutions perhaps this will come over
the course of the semester as we refine
our research through our theses for the
program taleghani an angel will be
speaking after me will expand on our
research findings in detail they will
speak more of exactly how our direct
experiences were able to compliment or
refute some of some of our scholarly
stances on modern India and China tell
to speak briefly on the issues of
migrant populations and education Jenny
will speak about urban and public space
and last but not least angel will
conclude our presentation with some
thoughts underwater implications of
globalization sustainability as well as
the post Imperial legacies of both
nations thank you so much
so one of the most significant but
largely on some contributors to China's
booming economy is migrant workers these
populations have helped transform the
Chinese economy over the past three
decades the new settlers of China's mega
cities also have created great
challenges for urban policy Shanghai has
23 million people nine million of which
are migrant population and among the 7.5
million people aged between 20 and 30
for sixty percent of them are migrants
we have a conversation with an informal
recycling worker in Beijing during a
conversation with angiogram beagle he
told us that the registration system or
hukou is the major factor which
prevented his waste recycling business
from receiving any protection of the law
the business which he had for over 15
years was eventually shut down by the
government during his decades of
struggle in the city he only got to see
his children wife during the Chinese New
Year holiday which is come which is the
common situation millions of migrant
families face addition to the immediate
issues of the relocated population such
as income inequality living condition
healthy issues etc we found ample
reasons to pay close attention to the
children of the migrants there are
390,000 children under the age of six
who are officially classified as
migrants in Shanghai in China's
registration system children born into
migrant families followed their parents
rural status regardless of where they
were born or currently live they face
serious challenges of social mobility as
they are barred from attending local
high schools depravity Ron schools in
Beijing for migrant children are often
ill-founded and often faced a Malaysian
or the suspension because the government
doesn't give all permitted permits to
these schools similar to Beijing and
Shanghai mumba cats 20,000 new Mike
from rural parts of India daily however
different than different from the
dominating working age my grandmother of
China India migrants tend to plant their
families including the elderly and the
young these arrivals usually settle in
slumps or arrival cities around mum Bay
where they can find jobs and a residence
through residents through their
connections back in their villages in
the Ravi one of the biggest slum slumps
in the world the migrants can't get
their first jobs in tanning shops and
plastic recycling factories and then
earn a space in the surrounding informal
structures the more fortunate of these
slum dwellers will manage to send their
children to private English teaching
schools for those new settlers they can
only imprint their children to their
work to their jobs such as construction
sites in mumbai there are 50,000
children live in construction sites and
one NGO we visited mom babe mobile
crouches strives to provide basic
education for their children including a
preschool and the bridge course to a to
facilitate older children entering local
schools these direct contacts help me
understand the information I read for
our course readings and added new
dimensions to abstract issues thank you
hello everybody my name is Jenny Han and
I'm studying economics and philosophy um
so one main focus during the trip was on
the different manifestations of
urbanization in Beijing Shanghai and
Mumbai we wanted to examine the urban
form being impacted by globalization is
this better so what are life living on
labor like and how are they visible in
space you know in order to be a skilled
knowledge gatherer while while being
sensitive to subtle social gender and
class differences we moved beyond the
traditional methodology of participatory
standard narrow
research we could not completely avoid
being urban warriors but we still tried
our best to use informal ways of looking
at power and politics by examining the
city spatially our research in Beijing
and Shanghai centered on environmental
NGO so I can only speak on behalf of the
NGOs that we encountered and with an
exception of very well recognized
international environmental NGO called
Greenpeace the offices of NGOs were for
the most part located in low storey
buildings with walk up stairs modest
office space with and plain furniture
the first NGO that we visited didn't
even have a signage posted in the
building so it was almost impossible to
find on the other hand government
organized non-governmental organization
as you can tell by its name are set up
by the Chinese government with a
propagandist agenda and these offices
were located in high story modern
buildings with very advanced technology
and water fountains exhibition rooms
flamboyant lobbies and colorfully woven
carpets and I think that sizes and
volumes relate to function and
indirectly tell us about society an
examination of the simple spatial
orientation of the NGOs and gang goes
reflects the carefully regulated Display
of power and control of space in the
Chinese government now moving on to
Mumbai I I did not observe this kind of
meticulous planning and construction of
the city and perhaps it may be more apt
to convey my experience of the city
using literary devices which is how they
were presented to us Mumbai is a city of
contradictions it's a city of heaven and
hell Ambani's 27 floor personal home
that is worth two billion dollars and is
maintained by 600 full-time staff towers
over Dorothy which is Asia's biggest
slum that extends
one point 75 kilometers kilometers rows
of five star exclusive hotels line up
along Marine Drive which is also an open
dumping ground for everybody in Mumbai
migrant workers and their children find
shelter in construction sites under
buildings while new buildings are being
built Mumbai is a city of creative
destruction and a work in progress as in
the words of Professor out it is a city
that is evolving organically influenced
by multiple internal factors where the
visibility of contradictions are readily
available to us the spatial examination
of the three cities finally was only one
methodology of many that we use during
the trip one important methodological
inside I gained was that so many of
these urban issues and themes are not
discrete topics but rather they're very
subtly linked to each other we cannot
talk about space without addressing the
issues of policymaking city planning
migration inequality poverty and
rehabilitation thank you hi everybody my
name is angel I'm a senior in the
college and I've been privileged to say
a few words in conclusion to our
presentation so coming from our time
abroad we as Mark said we were not
expecting to develop completely
innovative theories about environment
and urbanization in Asia nor were we
expecting to come up with genius
solutions to the issues we came across
rather we focused on formulating a new
method of thinking that synthesizes the
multitude of perspectives and approaches
to the problems at hand we aim to seek
points from of departure from
conventional perceptions of these two
countries and to foster
intersectionality between seemingly
separate disciplines within urbanization
and environment as Jenny said for while
our experiences were supplemented with
academic readings and lectures
throughout the field data that we
ultimately gathered spoke to quote what
life on the ground was actually like as
a fellow scholar
put it quote what did the different
policies between the two countries mean
for how people live their daily lives
how did these people think about the
policies if they even thought about them
at all perspectives that we gathered
from the ground up were crucial in
helping us formulate our own
perspectives and research interests some
among us have already noted preliminary
research findings on the behavioral and
operational modes of public and
non-governmental sectors the effects
that globalized urbanization has on
these molds and the nature's of the
relationships between government and
civil society and to vastly different
political frameworks and after gathering
all this data over the course of six
weeks we are now in the process of
synthesizing it we are asking questions
about the various frameworks that both
we and our hosts operated under the
prospective perspectives that we heard
from and the perspectives that we did
not hear from was our graham agenda in
fact representative or selectively of
the components of urbanization and
environment issues in China and India
are the various approaches the two
countries have to the issues productive
and do the benefits of these approaches
outweigh their costs these are only some
of the questions we came away with and
we are now in the process of exploring
them further in our fall seminar
together lastly and participating in
this pilot program and in sharing our
experiences and findings with you all
afterwards we hope to have shed some
light on why this opportunity to engage
in sort of field research as an
undergraduate is unique and valuable we
agreed to devote our summers and fall
semesters to this program knowing and
anticipating that it was designed
differently from any other study abroad
program we on this panel hope to have
contributed to the directions that
Columbia's current undergraduate study
and research model will take in the
future thank you
we now have comments from two people
have already been introduced to you
first can pruitt then then Nick Dirk's
and if there's any time left which I'm
kind of doubting we'll have a couple of
questions but otherwise I think this is
going to be an ongoing conversation so
let me just thank the students you guys
agree I wanted like well that was
remarkable I learned three things one of
a kind of a complicated intellectual
sort which I won't describe at length
but it turns out as we sort of know
theoretically but have now seen
interpersonally the the local is
universal and the global has got to be
contextualized these kind of complicated
theories we have about globalization and
so forth and so on they land in various
places and what we've heard from these
remarkable students are where they saw
that happening the second thing I
learned of a more programmatic sort is a
a lot of experiential learning can
happen in just a few weeks if things are
well put together and well implemented
it's a big if but nevertheless we don't
need endless amount of time to make sure
that students have a fundamentally
transforming experience a third I didn't
quite learn it but I kind of suspect it
that when it's not 20 but 200 or 2000
Columbia University undergraduates who
have had this experience Columbia will
be a global University no matter what we
think we want it just will be because
they will come back and they will make
demands on what they are taught and how
they are taught so I guess my final
comment is really too
the 20 or so students and indeed maybe
to everyone in the room we are in a
minority with respect to this issue with
respect to what we're learning from this
day and you have really got to help us
create the majority and that means two
things three things half a dozen things
it means that you've got to say to your
fellow students here you don't get it
you weren't there let me tell you what
it's really like to watch migrant
workers what it's really watch to watch
to watch transactions interactions until
you have that experience the you won't
get it you've got to have the analytic
studies of course you got other
languages and all the skills that
University provides but unless we blend
this with experiential learning it's not
going to take so you've got to help us
say that then you've got to say to your
faculty guess what you got to go deeper
you're not quite making sense out of it
for me given what I saw what I
experienced what I'm writing and push
push push the faculty to make sure
they're responsive to the educational
experience that you've had in this
program and the one you merit and
deserve while you're still here but
especially especially decide that before
you leave you're going to make sure that
Columbia University does not let go of
what you have pioneered and so 25 years
from now when you come back as
impoverished NGO workers you will be
very very proud to have put Columbia on
a new intellectual trajectory thank
I want to join Ken and say and I learned
a lot of things this afternoon most of
all I've learned that these
extraordinary accounts that you've given
us have vindicated our faith both in
students and in a new idea of what a
global university might actually mean
and I therefore I want to join my
colleagues and thanking and
congratulating you and indeed everyone
who made your experiences possible for
moving us really into a very new kind of
moment and a very exciting moment and
one which as Ken says in 25 years we
might actually be able to understand
better than we can today we as
professors Ellen said at Columbia have a
very international university with a
long and distinguished history of
international studies we are meeting
here with the emblem of the School of
International and public affairs draping
behind us and with the names of two
regional Institute's that have been
instrumental in making these experiences
possible and those of you who have been
around here for a while may know but not
all of you may that the School of
International and public affairs began
as the School of International Affairs
right after World War Two and it was
effectively built out of the regional
Institute's that themselves came out of
the experience of the United States in
World War two but it was a reflection in
large part of that moment that the way
International Studies developed was
towards developing graduate and
professional education and towards the
specialized kinds of scholarship that
led to the production of scholars like
many of us who are involved in this but
who nevertheless had very different
kinds of experiences not all of them
preparing us fully to grasp the meaning
of this evening's event I as a young
person had an opportunity to go to South
Asia because my father was a professor
not of anything outside North America
but through the Fulbright Program which
was a wonderful early example of a
program that really
changed a lot of people's lives I think
it even changed your life Lee right it
was in a different it was a different
program but okay but the the point of
this is that when a senator from
Arkansas developed a program and got it
passed through Congress I don't think he
fully understood the implications of
that for me it was simply a time when I
was 12 years old to go away for a year
which meant that when I went to college
I wanted to go back to India to learn
something about this place that had
struck me is so extraordinary and which
now has struck those of you who were in
Mumbai is so extraordinary through my
own experience of it but when i was in
college there were no programs like this
there were regular study abroad programs
at columbia we've had many wonderful
study abroad programs but there was
nothing that would allow me to go and do
the kinds of things that you did I went
off and in fact last summer I came upon
a letter that I had written to my
parents in the summer of nineteen
seventy one saying I didn't think things
were working very well I thought perhaps
I was going to just pack it all up and
come home and they wrote back and then
professors of mine from my college wrote
back and said you better stay try to
work it out it was very hard it was a
wonderful experience in the end but I
have been listening to you also with
envy for the kind of help you pad in
making these experiences possible in
organizing for you the serendipity but
nevertheless the structured serendipity
and there are lots of people behind this
of course that made these experiences
possible we at Columbia will continue to
do international studies the way we've
done it for many years will continue to
do study abroad the way we've done it
for years but we now know through this
evenings set of accounts that we can do
something fundamentally different we can
take on the challenge of the global in
all these different kinds of ways and
the projects that we heard described
from those of you who were in in Paris
ranging from architecture to to asthma
to photography and so on and the kinds
of experiences we've just heard from the
panel who spent the summer in Beijing
Shanghai and Mumbai
tell us just a small slice of the
possibilities that are in store for us
and that this wonderful collaboration
between regional Institute's that never
did this sort of thing global centers
that never existed Columbia University
that's always been global but never
global like this can produce especially
when you are students take advantage so
like Ken I'm going to challenge you to
tell your colleagues tell your friends
tell your fellow students to keep
pushing us to make sure that this is
just the beginning of an extraordinary
moment of new kinds of globalization for
the University and indeed for all of us
thank you everyone who's been involved
in this today and do we have any any
anybody who didn't go on the on these
wonderful experiences would like to ask
a question of our scholars who i think
are basically here anybody nobody yes
i'm wondering i'm wondering what you're
telling the your fellow students about
these programs really in the dorm sre in
the residence halls in the evening are
they asking about these programs are is
there any conversation about them you're
young and you can probably stand up and
speak loudly so who would like to answer
that question yeah go ahead stand up i
speaking i think the reaction i always
get is like why didn't i apply um I
really was extremely when I found out
about the program it was really kind of
short notice I saw it in my email and
then I was like okay I'm going to go on
vacation and then when I came back I was
like oh I have only a week left and I
need to apply and I didn't really know
exactly what I was getting myself into I
just knew it was compatible with my
architecture program and that I could
study abroad with it and but when I
started when I got there and I saw that
I was going to get so much more out of
it than just you know my spring or my
fall I constantly hear people saying one
semester when semester is never enough
um I I really tell people that they
should apply and that it's something
that you will absolutely never refer get
and that you learned so much from it and
so I mean to add to that
other than the amazing academic
experience um just the fact that we got
to know professor de grazia so well we
got to work with her so closely with her
and also Miriam and Malika back at
andreat all I mean this is an
opportunity to do research and to learn
from like some of the most amazing
researchers in academia and I mean you
know we didn't just get to know
professor to Grazia in the classroom we
had we had regular dinners that her
apartment in Paris and I mean that's
something that which was really amazing
professor de Rossi is an amazing cook um
but I mean it's something that I would
never thought could have happened to me
as an undergrad that I could be at my
professors apartment in Paris having
intellectual discussions about the
elections the presidential elections in
Paris and I mean I mean I just thought
it was just wonderful and that's what I
tell everyone not really about the
academic experience which is great but
just the fact that you get to interact
with your profess their in a way that
you could never do like usually as an
undergrad is there anybody from the
China yeah
um so I'm a senior before this trip I
think I had a lot of ideas about writing
a thesis and about kind of a lot of what
Stephanie mentioned about what my
academic experience it here at Ben and I
know a lot of other juniors and seniors
that I studied with have kind of
struggled with the same thing and so
since getting back I've talked to a lot
of especially rising juniors about this
program because I think it really even
though it was a short period of time it
was exhausting it was intense and I
think it really I've had this
conversation with other peers helped us
really gain a lot more confidence in not
just their ability to do research but
our ability to just think about what we
want to research what we want to learn
and why we're here which i think is
important for all of us as we're
graduating or just going on to the next
year school is kinda legitimizing that
and so a lot of students I've encouraged
to apply to help them figure that out
um or what I often speak about is the is
the rigor of the program because when
were there I felt like you know we were
really pretty much at a master's level
you know course it wasn't a study abroad
I think often what people associate
particularly with study abroad programs
in Europe that they're sort of vacation
programs there's a romantic notion
especially about being in Europe but I
think what this program does really well
is a sort of show the diffuse maybe more
oblique ways that inequality still
exists across Europe and I think that's
what really differentiates it from other
programs abroad especially in Europe
who's the real well I said I won leave
but here I am uh it's it's more of a
request to the student participants in
both programs please keep in touch with
us and let us have your feedback in the
sense of as we continue to develop the
program any problems any logistical
issues technical issues because I'm
coming back in the january and i really
want to hear from you then i'm sure now
you'll be hearing from you before then
but then i want to encourage all of you
in both programs to keep open lines of
communication with us because your input
is important as anybody else's since
it's based on real lived experiences
things let me also say that I mean
you're the first groups but whenever
whenever we do something like this and
and and there's a kind of group sense of
group identity develop you want to stay
in touch with us so that you can also
connect with the with the students who
go the next time and the next time after
that so by the time you're an old lady
or old guy like me you've had
generations of Columbia students that
you've related to who've had a growing
experience like this so so please do
keep keep in touch with us and I also
want to say that um there are lots of
opportunities
on campus that undergraduates often
don't take advantage of because they
don't know about it and now your
insiders your members of these regional
Institute's so please come to our events
because there are a lot of people here
that we that come here that are talking
about the issues that you've been
interested in and tell your friends that
undergraduates are really very welcome
it's not hard to get across amsterdam
avenue so we we hope to see you again a
lot